a big question of the day are you  watching the tennis on the second screen  oh no uh i'm uh i'm boycotting uh  i i've it's it's it's been a tradition  to always  watch the the final on on the day of um  the last round  uh and sometimes like if i played  if the final has been really really long  and i play along  i play a relatively short last run game  i can even watch some after the game is  finished but uh  i'm boycotting  this year  unfortunately  but um i i did follow a little bit of  the score of of the finals so is your  boy  watching it or he seems to be he seems  to be in some slight trouble yeah but  maybe he gets a  to break back in in game four of  this set and then it's back on track  we'll see